大家好,下面我来给大家介绍一下在分销商模式下怎样手动同步数据,也就是说您是这个分销商网的毛医院,您需要手动从您的上级分销商处同步数据过来,比如说它的某个商品增加了SQ,那么您需要把这个变动给同步过来,这个时候能用到了手动同步数据,您点击这里。
在这个菜单下,您首先需要创建一个同步规则,点击添加同步规则,这个名字是可以随便起的。
数据来源，定模式。您可以有两种选择,一种是用商家编码,就是您和商级分销商所对应的商品,他们都用商家编码,并且在整个店铺里都是唯一的,这个时候可以用这种。
这次来演示一下使用,实时同步的关系,这个是在最后的财团,实时同步数据这里,您已经设置了您这个商品和上级分销商店铺中某个商品的关联关系已经设置过了,这时候您可以选择使用这种方式。
这种方式更适合于于第一您在这边已经设置过了关联关系了,第二您这个商品不一定有商家编码,或者说有商家编码,但是不一定唯一,这时候您最好就是用下面这个方式。
好了,下面这是这个规则的状态,还有这些要同步的数据,您都可以选择,比如说您要同步那个SKO有些增加或者变动,这个肯定要勾选这个了。
这样的话,您想同步也可以勾选这个。
其他的还有一些,比如说铸图,包括一些SKO的图片,这些都可以,包括一些描述都可以。
那最后一个您看一下,这边实时同步,如果开启之后的话,那么在这个手动同步结束之后的话,
这两个商品,您这个店铺的商品还有您上级分享相对应的商品,
给它创建一条实时同步的关联关系,就放在这个菜单下。
我们先暂时先关掉,先点个确定。
好了,这条规则已经创建好了。
在这里的话,可以看到要同步了哪些,然后可以随时查看,点这里可以编辑,或者说删除。
这里可以暂时的进用,或者说再启用这条规则。
那么现在选择商品,我们要对商品进行同步了。
同步的在之前的话,要先把您这个店铺的商品跟同步规则进行关联。
我们来试一个,比如说把这个商品,到现在这里显示是未关联。
我们选择关联,刚才这个规则,您把它关联一下。
您再看这条商品的话,这里已经显示了。
它跟这个规则已经关联好了,可以点击,您可以随时查看,或者说编辑这个规则都是可以的。
下面我们来把这个商品进行一下同步。
首先它这个规则已经好了,接下来我们就更方便了,只要勾选它,然后点击立即同步。
我们点这个,选中的商品一个,就可以了。
当然这里有其他的选项,您可以全店同步,或者说同步出售中的,或者所有查询处的同步都可以。
另外这边这个按钮的话,它多一个选项,就是说您在最后一步会给您,让您去设定一个时间,您可以在其他的时间。
比如说每天的几点,我们去进行一次同步,这些都可以设置。
我们现在就马上同步一次,来勾选这个,然后点一个确定。
好了,这就提交成功了,我们到这边这个标签来看一下,可以看到这个同步任务,这是刚刚提交过来的。
一边有一个商品,这里有正在执行中,这个是不需要这点等的,您是可以随时可以去赶别的事情,或者说关掉浏览器,它都会在后台自动给您同步,这是不受影响的。
好了,我们点一下查看,查询已经看到这个已经成功了,手动同步已经结束了,点任务ID,可以自动调查过来,可以看到。
同步的原商品,原店铺,目标店铺,目标商品,还包括同步了一个图片,就是一张主图,包括它的编号,状态以及实践。
在这个页面上,您可以导出同步的一些记录,您如果有同步失败的,您可以在这里选择失败,然后把它筛选出来,查询出来之后点击重新同步,去把这些失败的再同步一次。
这里就给大家介绍,这就是手动同步数据。